like you know you can see you're a smart
boy I'm in this creation you can see all
the like you know even ourselves look
you have a nose next to your mouth
so it's very hard for me to
foreignty teaching to observe this must
be a creative Creator but you know this
created
we split them yeah we're happy with that
yes
they made me five million pounds
because stupid people like you that's
what happens you make it look stupid
look this is
always
except Islam because your enemy of Islam
where is the uh
to know there is a creator for this
creation
like like you know either this creation
was created by a Creator or nothing
which one makes sense Creator hope it's
just knowledge
I've lived that that long without it so
I just don't see a point now where's
your mind how old are you if you don't
mind asking how old are you
24. I've lived 24 years
he became Muslim when he was 17. you
know for 17 years he did not believe in
he believed in God yeah yeah but you
have to understand brother wow said you
look you know like I said he said he
makes sense but because you've been
brought up in a different uh Society or
environment but we have to understand if
something makes sense and it's a truth
regards about our parents I'm gonna
follow my father and my mother because
they worship something look I have to
follow my own way if something makes
sense to me and it's logical and it's
rational you know
I know you're fine but Islam you make a
perfect sense it doesn't make profit yes
if I was I wish sometimes I wish I was
born as a Muslim
once you have a family that is not they
don't have a place I like people
there's
zipper for them
yeah but you see you see here if you
accept Islam you'll get bitter reward
then some Muslims
like you left something which is
disbelief and you accept Islam you can
they tell people that's a Muslims
no doubt about that because what the
biggest crime I guess God when you turn
away from him
for us
that's what we wish that's why I'm not
no that's what Hitler wants that's what
Stalin wants that's what the the tyrants
wants the tyrants words that there is
nothing after life because it killed
many people there's nothing happened to
him
no one has ever gone
no
they did they did yeah
he went there and he saw it so the
Hellfire and he's so Paradise yeah
because Prophet Muhammad Jesus as well
Moses and they are trustworthy honest
but what we say to you within us we
believe Justice must be established
where do we get that feeling and that
desire for justice if we just have to
die where are we getting that desire
which is it's not something we learn
from society it's not something within
us and I can show you that you know a
child if a child ship over the table and
you hit the tape the trust are crying if
you hit the table the child stop crying
and believes he got his Justice back but
who said to the child you need to get
your Justice back to feel happy
I'll repeat again a ciao that is five
let's say two years old yeah if he falls
on a table and a table hurts him yeah he
starts crying yeah so what you do you
come and you hit the table say tables
you're not seeing for making them cry
the child will stop crying
why he stopped crying because he
believes you got his right back for him
by hitting the table I'm gonna stop my
points
even children are born naturally to
believe Justice should be established if
it's the case therefore where are we
getting that desire for justice if we
just born from like just Randomness why
we have to appreciate Justice
if we are born just Randomness why do we
have to appreciate Justice even babies
do appreciate Justice
and there's many people who are
criminals
work right the murderers they haven't
not got Justice yet but they will get to
get it in the day of judgment
in the stand
you know what I would say to you Lee
yeah imagine you die
and you you'll be you die and you meet
God
imagine you die
I'm
gonna happen
what are you gonna do it'd be too late
for you
I mean you're gonna be more loser than
me because me if I die and I become dust
there's nothing to regret because that's
not regret but if you die and you meet
God oh you should speak about it deeply
now
because the Christians the Christians
say if I don't
God then I'll go to their house so how
how
you show me that but if I believe in you
that helps that's a good question the
question is asking Lee he said the
Christians tell him that if you don't
believe in our God you go to hell
yeah
go to there that's right however we the
the Muslims and the Jews and the
Christians they have the same concept of
the god of Abraham yes however God gave
us brain doesn't make any sense you
believe in God become a baby that's why
Christianity doesn't make any sense if
God become a baby someone
alhamdulillah
no even Judaism Judaism is a tribal God
only cares about Israel Israelites no
Allah is the god that cares about you
and me and everyone else because he's
the god of everyone else you see and
look how Allah described himself
for everyone says that
no but what I'm saying to you you on
break analyze look Christianity God
become a baby then God he had to kill
himself to forgive me it doesn't make
any sense
Judaism the god of Judaism is a tribal
God only cares about Israelites
yes that's what I'm saying no you know
preferring people over other people
there's no harm with that like you know
what I'm saying that it cares only about
the Israelites the other people go to
create them by the Chinese the Arabs
they've been created
as these things but when it comes to
Islam No god creates you and me and all
of us to worship him alone regardless if
you are Chinese you are Japanese and
Algerian Moroccan Pakistani Saudi
regardless where you're from you are
here to worship your creator to show
appreciation to your creator but before
we go to that League I'm saying to you
look logically rationally we have to
have there is a Creator who creates
creation
you accept that yes okay
yeah who believe that
in the Quran Allah Prophet Muhammad also
said every newborn every newborn is born
with Etc is it only a natural
destination to believe in a Creator to
believe in what in a Creator so what
happened in Oxford University you know
Oxford University yes they did study
they took children from different parts
of the world and they spent 1.9 million
on these projects three years and they
came to know that if you leave children
alone they will grow up believe in God
so the question you ask yourself Lee how
a prophet Muhammad who existed
who existed 1 400 years ago knew that
children are born to believe in God
naturally how he knew that sir which God
are you talking about the good of
Chinese
yeah okay show me show me from the Quran
where
I know
me Allah
I'm Christian
I'm the father of Jesus
yes
foreign
[Music]
Jesus is coming to make peace for each
and every one of us because he died for
all of us
comes back
if Jesus comes back now and he doesn't
accept him he doesn't accept Jesus if
Jesus come back now yeah if a Jesus
returned right now and he says to him I
don't want to accept you at all what
she's gonna do to him
and he said father forgive them for they
know not what they do okay so Those Who
Kill Jesus
Those Who Kill Jesus they're going to be
with him in Paradise of course they can
be they can be a family that's the logic
help me with him this is not just thank
you very much
the murderers they're gonna leave him
what what is not fair if if evil people
go to heaven it's not fair it's not fair
yeah
it's not even even people don't have to
reject him what kills the guard for what
is God for to forgive our sins no no he
killed himself
even though even though we are sinner
he's a pagan worshiper we are sinner
even for our forefather
don't push people yeah
babies you unbelievable
[Music]
it's okay
in the beginning
to kill the babies alive
no baby so Isis
Isis they are more inclined to Christ to
the Bible than to us because Prophet
Muhammad teach us clearly in a world
don't kill babies don't kill women
in the bible teach them to kill babies
it doesn't make sense to you animals and
everything he's the proof he's the
biggest proof he's the biggest
foreign
will become widespread okay even if you
are not involved directly will affect
you now by default if you open a bank
account your money is being used for
interest that's right
interesting interest what is it I know
that you're in need
yes do you know about 2009
the crisis yeah what caused it
makes the richest who's interested
foreign
no no you can if you go if you go
there's a NatWest they do that for you
they give you free interest however
they still use your money for other
things but they don't they don't yeah
Investments but they don't put interest
in your bank but interests it makes them
Rich richer and a poor poorer Islam
teach me if you are in need I should
help you not should utilize your need to
enslave you or manipulate you
people
okay yeah
for example if I have a bank and all of
you are in need of money so I'm Gonna
Give You 500 pounds give it to me back
600 or 1000 yes and all of you you're
gonna do the same thing but I know
you're taking a risk maybe you're not
even going to be successful in your
business then you're gonna ask me more
money I'm gonna put you more interest
you understand so interest is Injustice
it's oppression against mankind you know
transaction in Islam is halal do
business no problem but interest is like
I said make the rich richer and a poor
poorer understand interest is a type of
manipulation
to help to flourish rather interest
bring the Western world
properties
yeah they help you yeah
no so what they do they say look there's
no interest yeah no no no interest yeah
you see we borrow you money they borrow
your money and give it back to where you
get you you got the money
they can't do interest
again you see how they cheat
that's what Islam teach me interests
Haram with the Muslims or non-muslims
you know Prophet Muhammad to us give
someone deceive you don't deceive it
be honest with him
in the stand but I will bring you back
to other prophecy understand why Islam
is a truth because you know there is
Creator no doubt no who is the true
creator when you look at Islam Allah
described himself
you ready yeah but they changed it like
Christians they made God into three Gods
the father
the Son and the Holy Spirit and they
said they are one God I don't know which
school they've been to because one plus
one plus one how many three
I don't know one plus one plus one is
one this is a Christian nonsense you
know that's why we should ask the screws
to be shut down who's teaching one plus
one plus one it's equal one in the stand
nonsense and the worst thing is they say
the father is a fully God
if the father is
we have one God say no no no no no we
have Jesus is also fully God okay so we
have to God say no no no no we don't
have to cause we still have one God okay
enough no no with another one the holy
spirit is fully good
that's what that's not what they said in
the Bible
you're right yeah
the Christian made up the Christian was
Christianity was corrupted by Paul
foreign
so he said he saw the cross behind the
Sun and Constantine and his father they
used to worship the Sun
in the stand so what I would say to you
to go back Allah described himself in
the Quran he's the only one
he is
a master self-sufficient everything is
in need of him
he's not in need of nothing
you know God itself
sufficient you understand let me yelling
he'll be get nuts neither was he
begotten
and there's nothing similar to Allah
there's nothing like unto him he's the
creator of everything in the stand and I
believe in Moses yes I believe in Jesus
yes I believe in Abraham but like I
believe Jesus teaching and Moses
teaching was corrupted okay but I have
another question
what do you think was said so far if you
ask me question does he make sense about
the prophecy how Prophet Muhammad
existed
1400 years ago he sent us something we
can observe right now like you know by
the interest that's because 500 years
ago interest will never widespread
now interest is you cannot Escape it
sometimes
the question you ask yourself Lee is
sincerely honestly how Amanda existed 1
500 years ago or longer telling us about
something we can see right now
because he's a messenger of the Creator
and the Creator knows everything
so the Creator he told the prophet
Muhammad
about some things will happen in the
future and one of them is interesting
you know is the other one
No Doubt
but no instance
no everything everything
no some of them has happened yet because
why because look we call it we call it
Arabic the science of the day of
judgments meaning there is some events
will happen before their judgmented some
of them are major and a minor the major
one has not happened yet but the minor
one majority of them is husband or still
happening for example Prophet Muhammad
said that the mother the the market will
be close to you
you start buying things and you become
because back in those days sometimes you
have to travel like days to go to a
market or to buy things he said the
market to become very close to you meet
the school has mentioned that you'll be
easy for you to purchase things now
literally you're at home with your phone
and you can buy things it's so close to
you
and that it was not like this before
Islam
no no so we believe Daddy we shared
similarities between Christianity like
for example we believe in Jesus they
believe in Jesus
however Islamic teaching is unique
because Islamic teaching is universal
Christianity when Jesus came Jesus did
not come for everyone he came for the
Israelites that's why he's teaching is
not for everyone also Moses and let me
tell you something clear remember the
European brought Christianity to Africa
and to um to to South America at
Australia and to Canada yeah the same
people that were forcing people to
accept Christianity that abandoned
Christianity Europe is no Christian like
before
you know like you know the Europe is not
close to that before yes
Sunday go church is empty
so what they did they found Christianity
is declining Islam in Britain
Christianity is declining Islam is
inclined it's increasing increasing
going up even though there is a huge war
against Islam on social or on the
mainstream media they make is terrorist
terrorists you know but Islam is
spreading
when they want to make something
that's true that's true and Islam is the
truth Islam comes to protect your mind
Islam come to protect your health Islam
comes to protect your wealth Islam comes
to protect the society that's why Islam
will have something Capital punishments
which came to preserve five things
these five things another five pillars
Islam is different which is very
important and let me please elaborate
understanding
Islam came to preserve five things yeah
projects the first Islam came to
preserve and protect religion what does
that mean
Islam atheism paganism politicism is not
allowed because women Worship in the
true God you start following your
desires and when we start following our
own desires we can see what's happening
now a man is confused if he's a man or
woman a woman is confused if she's a
chicken or a rat the chicken is even the
chicken in Europe is confused you know
that's the outcome of not following the
true God understand that's the first
thing the second one Islam came to
preserve intellect that's what alcohol
and drugs is forbidden Islam
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why Cumberland and interest is
forbidden hopefully Islam came to
preserved family and lineage that's why
fornication and adultery is forbidden in
Islam lastly Islam came to preserve life
that's why committing suicide killing
people unjustly is forbidden these five
things if we do preserve them we will
have a good Society what is the opposite
of that alcohol destroyed us Cumberland
destroy us fornication destroy us
interests destroy us and all of that
goes back to the most evil thing when
you worship false god and that can be
your desires or a tree or Jesus or
Muhammad because the true God is Allah
the question I will ask you that's why
all people ask you that's why you see
are empowered
empowering the money from our suffering
from alcohol gambling interest and they
look at Islam as a threat for their
business
so what they do because they're rich
they will utilize their will and their
money to make Islam look bad even though
Islam is good for us individually and
collectively the question that I will
ask you how a man is said to this
Capital enough how a manly that existed
1400 years ago who couldn't read and
write he's coming with is a perfect way
of life
he lives in the middle of desert who
couldn't read and write he never went to
any University he came with the perfect
way of life on the other hand we have
these politicians who studied in the
best universities around the world
Oxford University's Harvard Universities
yet they cannot resolve the problems but
every problem in the world there is
solution for it in Islam
you know why
how you just told me that's good how you
hate it
but you just told me except that it's
good
you just told me you do accept as a
creator
yeah so you know it is
what happens say Islam came 600 years
after yeah what happens if you say next
year some someone someone came
to be a prophet no we don't need that
because why the Islamic teaching like I
said to you how do you know that
because Prophet Muhammad said it
and we we know he was a truthful person
that Jesus Christ is claimed to be the
last prophet no never he said there's
someone coming after him
so
too much information
you Chinese man
you had a Chinese mashallah too many
information don't worry
you can't accept what is
extreme yes
oh you like cocktail
examples of how
Muhammad prophesied
Michael
but I'm sure there's some bits in the
Quran that's they don't match up with
what we have observed today no never
never never never ever in the Quran is
the truth of course you're gonna do your
own recession I hope even even
God
become baby it doesn't make sense
foreign
yes University they have their own
curriculum their own methodology you're
not gonna accept the university this I'm
gonna study in the University but I'm
gonna take your curriculum that's like
the other university of curriculum to
say no no you're wrong there's a method
to follow in the stand so my point here
is if we accept Allah is the creator
Prophet Muhammad is a true Prophet logic
dictates logic rational dictate that you
have to believe it came with
receive a nice guy but what I would say
to you you know what you just said to me
you prove my points
I've been doing this for the last 15
years yeah
majority of times those who don't accept
Islam either because of a psychology
psychological factor or a social Factor
U1 is a psychological Factor what
happened to you right now you knew
things not only spoke to me you think
hang on so everything that I knew is
wrong what this person is telling me the
truth so what are you gonna do either
you're gonna think you know what it's
not about what I learned in the past
it's about what is the truth what makes
sense however you can accept it or what
is going to happen to you you're gonna
start looking for any ways to turn away
from the truth what I will say to you
when you go home yeah pray to God you
say all the creator of everything open
my heart to the truth because what I can
do I cannot change your heart I can I
can teach you I can speak to you
rationally logically however changing
the heart as we belongs to Allah and for
you is what takes a step okay
thank you very much people give me your
time and keep watching my videos
thank you very much my name is
do you know my channel
this is our Channel
they recommend you
you see the beautiful face mashallah